hey nice place you got here i'm honestly
impressed
please don't don't do this to me who put
this in here this is a joke right
you know about reagan right huh he he
probably read it oh my oh
okay i feel like anyone who has this
much stephen king is
who is this anyone who has this much
stephen king i feel like probably
supports
deforestation james joyce we get it you
think you're better than everyone
nobody's actually this pretentious
please tell me that this is hollowed out
and there's like a gun in here because
that would be
preferable to actual words okay you got
dune because you're in for the hype and
you want to see timothee chalamet
shine on the screen okay we get it we
stand timote okay
timothy timothy what do you know the
fact that you have this many
fantasy books probably means you're a
terrible tipper because
i am also a terrible tipper brandon
sanderson literally killed a person
i think you mean he killed a character i
cannot tell the difference
i'm sorry just every six months i have
to get mad at the same 10 books i do not
make the rules
calvin and hobbes are war criminals